the subway system in new york city
rendered unusable
hundreds of thousands still without
power in louisiana in the heat of the
summer
one of the world's most powerful nations
struggling with the consequences of
extreme weather driven by climate change
this is a growing global problem from
commuters submerged in china after
record rainfall
to western europe where it took weeks to
restore essential services after
catastrophic flooding
to the strain of heat and drought
affecting agriculture water supplies and
the electricity grid
as climate change intensifies so will
the pressure on our infrastructure
one of the big problems is that many of
the world's major cities like london
were built on water around rivers and
ports it's what helped to make them so
prosperous in the first place so
economically and socially important and
now in the face of climate change it's
also what's making them vulnerable
concrete covered urban environments
aren't designed to absorb water we need
better drainage improved physical
barriers and much more
there are costs
along the way that taxpayers government
will impose those costs on us as
taxpayers
but the alternative is what we have to
think about the alternative to doing
that
is more more places get flooded costs
actually increase
because you know you've got to rebuild
your house or you can no longer live
where you wanted to live or there are
more extreme events and wildfires and so
on
against this dramatic backdrop world
leaders are preparing for a crucial un
climate summit
they know the expense of adapting to the
change that's already here is mounting
and so is the cost of investing in
emissions reductions
the challenge now is finding a way to do
both
hannah thomas peter sky news